the old fashion has a pretty good claim
to being one of the most popular
cocktails of all time it's certainly one
of my favorites but even though it's
traditionally made with whiskey it's
surprisingly adaptable to lots of other
spirits so today I'm going to show you
one my favorite variations on the old
fashioned the Applejack roll is
fashioned for this cocktail you're going
to need some apple brandy some maple
syrup preferably a grade B maple syrup
it's a little bit richer some Angostura
bitters and some aromatic bitters and
then finally an orange peel for garnish
we're going to start with two ounces of
apple brandy apple Brandy's popularity
in America goes back well before the
Revolutionary War in fact the first
commercial distillery in the whole
United States
distilled apple brandy it's really great
on its own and it's excellent on
cocktails so now we're going to add a
bar spoon of maple syrup which is about
half a teaspoon really don't need very
much be careful because it can get sweet
really fast now we're gonna add our
bitters we're gonna do two dashes of
Angostura bitters which are pretty much
the most common bitters in the world
also the most useful if you only own one
brand of bitters haven't read this one
and finally I like to add a dash of
aromatic bitters aromatic bitters are a
broad category but they usually are
darker and have more baking spice notes
like cinnamon and nutmeg which obviously
are going to play great with our maple
syrup and rapid Randy all right now
we're ready to stir because this is all
alcohol over 90 to the percent alcohol
we don't want to shake it you want to
preserve that nice silky texture stir
for about 30 seconds or so I'm going to
serve this on the rocks because it's so
stiff a little extra dilution is a good
thing of course using fresh ice is
always key for really strong drinks like
this keeps them colder and now we're
gonna garnish this with an orange peel
peel a nice swamp so you just want to
pinch it lightly so the oil sprays over
the glass with all those dark earthy
notes and then it's nice to have those
aromatics from the orange oil to
brighten it up there you are and that is
the Applejack old fashioned this is a
great Thanksgiving drink
I love after the big meal sitting in
front of the fireplace sipping on one of
these surrounded by family it's
something I look forward to every year
if you like that drink subscribe to the
GQ channel for more